Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家分享一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师 Lisa Johnson 发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge”（循环收入竞赛）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Mary Entrant Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面 Dr. Marianne Trent，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是 Marianne Trent 博士，欢迎收听《Aspiring Psychologist》（有志心理学家）播客。
Thank you for joining me. This episode is scheduled to be released on Monday the 14th of November 2022. If you are listening to it in that week, then please do bear in mind that the application deadline for the doctorate in clinical psychology for the clearinghouse applications is 1pm on Wednesday the 16th of November. I'm sure that won't have passed you by, but I just wanted to get that on your radar. So today's episode is a guest episode and I am joined by Alicia Hussain and it would be advantageous for you to listen to the episode on values if you haven't done so already. That is episode 42 of the podcast, so if you haven't
感谢你的收听。本期节目定于 2022 年 11 月 14 日星期一发布。如果你是在那一周收听，请务必记住，临床心理学博士课程通过清算所（Clearinghouse）申请的截止日期是 11 月 16 日星期三下午 1 点。我相信你一定不会错过，但我只是想提醒你一下。今天的节目是嘉宾访谈，Alicia Hussain 加入了我的行列。如果你还没有听过关于“价值观”的那期节目，建议你先去听一下，那是本播客的第 42 期。所以如果你还没有
listened to that it might be useful for you to do that and then come back here for episode 49 but if you want to plow on regardless please do um so alicia and i met on linkedin and well you will you will find out um how and why we got chatting but it's all about values and we decided it would be useful to have a conversation about Alicia's culture, faith and background and how they align and how she keeps striving for her values as an aspiring psychologist whilst staying true to her other values, both personally and professionally, too. I hope you'll find it super interesting and super useful. I know I did and I will catch you on the other side. Hi, welcome along. It is our first guest episode for a while. I'm delighted to introduce you to Alicia Hussain. Hi Alicia. Hi. Thank you so much for coming on and thank you also for giving me the idea originally for the values based podcast episode. Very welcome. I think when I kind of put out a LinkedIn post, I feel like you're really active
听过那期节目，建议你先去听听，然后再回来听第 49 期。但如果你想直接继续听也没问题。我和 Alicia 是在领英（LinkedIn）上认识的，你会了解到我们是如何以及为何开始交谈的。这期节目完全围绕“价值观”展开，我们认为讨论 Alicia 的文化、信仰和背景，以及它们如何与她的价值观保持一致，以及她作为一名有志心理学家如何在保持个人和职业价值观的同时，坚持追求自己的目标，会非常有意义。希望你会觉得这期节目既有趣又实用。我知道我收获颇丰，我们稍后见。嗨，欢迎收听。这是我们久违的第一期嘉宾访谈。我很高兴向大家介绍 Alicia Hussain。你好，Alicia。你好。非常感谢你来参加节目，也感谢你最初为这期基于价值观的播客提供了灵感。非常欢迎。我想当我发布那条领英动态时，我觉得你真的很活跃
on LinkedIn. And I always kind of like your posts and things like that. So it was really kind of helpful to have that episode to kind of help me with thinking about values. So that was really helpful for me. Good. I love I love LinkedIn I do I can't I can't I can't deny it um but yeah thank you for being um involved and engaged with me on there so um but then after that we thought well actually this is really interesting to think about you specifically and some of your values um and specifically we thought it might be useful um in terms of your career but but also your culture and your background. Yeah. Yeah. I think I think it's always nice to kind of like watch your podcasts and think about people who've kind of already been through that journey.
在领英上。我总是很喜欢你的动态之类的。所以那期节目对我思考价值观非常有帮助。这对我也很有帮助。太好了。我非常喜欢领英，我无法否认这一点。但谢谢你在那上面与我的互动和参与。在那之后，我们觉得深入探讨你个人以及你的一些价值观会非常有趣，特别是考虑到你的职业、文化和背景。是的。我觉得观看你的播客，了解那些已经走过这段旅程的人，总是很棒。
But I think it would be really nice to kind of share, share my journey. And hopefully when people listen to it, I can either relate to it or maybe kind of think about the differences or like just inspire them around their own journey. So hopefully it can have an impact on people. Absolutely. I think it's so useful when we are working in mental health to be able to have, you know, examples of people that we can kind of hold as case studies. So if people don't know much about, you know, your faith, your culture, or, you know, how it might be, even for someone living in a different part of the country, you know, it's useful for people to have that awareness. So I think it's, yeah, thank you so much for doing this.
但我认为分享我自己的旅程也会非常好。希望当人们听到它时，要么能产生共鸣，要么能思考其中的差异，或者仅仅是受到启发，去开启他们自己的旅程。希望这能对人们产生影响。绝对是这样。我认为在心理健康领域工作时，能够拥有一些我们可以作为案例研究的人是非常有用的。所以，如果人们对你的信仰、文化，或者即使是对于生活在国家不同地区的人来说，了解这些情况都是有益的。所以我认为，是的，非常感谢你做这件事。
But also we realised in our discussion before we got started was that you're our first aspiring psychologist on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which feels a bit wrong. So yeah, I'm sorry, it's taken me 10 months to get here. But I know we had Rose, who is a trainee, but you were our first non-trainee aspiring psychologist. So yes, thank you so much for coming on. And if you're listening to this episode, or if you're watching on YouTube as well um and you're thinking oh i might like to come on the podcast i'm an aspiring psychologist please do get in contact with me um and as you as alicia said you can't miss me on socials i'm dr marianne trent
而且我们在开始前的讨论中也意识到，你是《Aspiring Psychologist》播客的第一位“有志心理学家”嘉宾，这感觉有点不对劲。所以，抱歉，我花了 10 个月才走到这一步。我知道我们之前有 Rose，她是一位实习生，但你是我们第一位非实习生的“有志心理学家”。所以，非常感谢你的到来。如果你正在收听这期节目，或者也在 YouTube 上观看，并且心想“我也想上这个播客，我是一名有志心理学家”，请务必联系我。正如 Alicia 所说，你在社交媒体上很容易找到我，我是 Marianne Trent 博士，
most places so don't be shy do get in contact or just engage with my content we'll get into conversations and marvelous things can happen so al Alicia tell me a little bit about yourself um a little bit personally a little bit professionally if that's okay yeah so um well where do I start so yeah so I suppose um I'm Muslim by background and um I've kind of been pursuing psychology I'd probably say since school um I think kind of outside of psychology I kind of just like to kind of focus on my own well-being I've started to try to be more persistent with going to things like gym and things like that and hopefully something that I can kind of get back into so I have been kind of trying to take some time to look after myself um I think my journey within kind of psychology started probably in school. So I was really lucky to do psychology as a GCSE, which I think when I did it, it wasn't really heard of. So it's this new, exciting thing. And yeah, it really kind of interested me.
在大多数平台上都是。所以别害羞，联系我，或者参与我的内容互动，我们就会开始交流，奇妙的事情就会发生。那么，Alicia，请向大家介绍一下你自己，个人和职业方面都可以，好吗？好的，从哪里开始呢？我想，我是穆斯林背景，从学校起我就一直在追求心理学。我想在心理学之外，我更倾向于关注自己的身心健康。我开始尝试更坚持地去健身房之类的，希望这能成为我能重新坚持下去的事情。所以我一直在尝试花时间照顾自己。我想我在心理学方面的旅程大概是从学校开始的。我很幸运在 GCSE 阶段就选修了心理学，我想在我那个时候，这并不常见。所以这是一件新鲜、令人兴奋的事情。是的，它确实让我很感兴趣。
But yeah, I think when I kind of started looking into it, I found it really helpful. But I think when I had my own kind of difficulties with mental health health it really opened up my eyes around what I want to pursue in the future and I think having my own experiences of mental health really kind of guided me in into this career pathway and I'm thinking about how I can move on from my experiences and how I can reflect on my experiences to kind of help others um so yeah I suppose when I when I started college I did psychology um as an A level and I was volunteering with Childline at the time so I find it a really helpful experience to be able to kind of have some direct contact with young people and start kind of giving back and using the things that I've
但当我开始深入研究时，我发现它非常有帮助。但当我自己在心理健康方面遇到困难时，它真正让我大开眼界，让我明确了未来想要追求的方向。我认为我自己的心理健康经历确实引导我走上了这条职业道路，我正在思考如何从我的经历中走出来，以及如何反思我的经历来帮助他人。所以，我想当我上大学时，我选修了心理学 A-level，当时我在 Childline 做志愿者。我发现这是一次非常有益的经历，能够与年轻人直接接触，开始回馈社会，并利用我
experienced and using my knowledge to kind of help other people um and then kind of giving back and using the things that I've experienced and using my knowledge to kind of help other people and then kind of going on from that I started in university, did my psychology degree and also kind of started building up my experience so I was really lucky to have the experience to volunteer so yeah so when I was uh volunteering um alongside my degree I volunteered in a place called Paws which is a mental health drop-in uh centre for young people um and it was one of the most eye-opening experiences I've had because not only kind of just working with young people and supporting them but just kind of how a service that's so easily accessible can have such an impact on young people's lives.
经历过的事情和我的知识来帮助他人。然后从那里开始，我上了大学，获得了心理学学位，也开始积累经验。我很幸运有机会做志愿者。所以，当我在攻读学位的同时做志愿者时，我在一个叫 Paws 的地方工作，那是一个为年轻人提供的心理健康咨询中心。这是我经历过最开阔眼界的体验之一，不仅是因为与年轻人一起工作并支持他们，更是因为一个如此容易获得的资源能对年轻人的生活产生如此大的影响。
So I really kind of enjoyed just getting to know people, kind of working with people and kind of getting my head around how things worked and having that opportunity to kind of support people and actually learn more about psychology in the process. So for me, that was really powerful um I had the opportunity to to be employed by the service which was was really amazing to be honest and I loved my time there so um I would just kind of work with people when they kind of dropped into the service around kind of any of their um any of their emotional health and well-being needs and
所以我真的很享受去了解人们，与他们一起工作，并弄清楚事情是如何运作的，以及有机会支持人们，并在过程中学到更多关于心理学的知识。对我来说，这非常有力量。我有机会被该服务机构聘用，老实说这真的很棒，我非常喜欢在那里的时光。所以，我会与那些来到服务中心的人一起工作，处理他们任何关于情感健康和福祉的需求，以及
whatever they wanted to talk about really um so that really put me in a good stead when I was thinking about applying for assistant psychologist posts so I was really lucky to get an assistant psychologist post straight after my role there and that's where I'm working at the moment so I'm currently working within Black Country Healthcare Trust within a service called Action for Children which kind of covers the area of Staffordshire and basically I work with young people again young people and children and I think I've really found it helpful to work with young people and children I think potentially when I when I'm working with young people I kind of reflect on my own experiences of struggling with my mental health when I was a child so I think it was just something that I found really kind of um helpful
他们真正想谈论的任何事情。这为我申请助理心理学家职位打下了良好的基础。我很幸运在那个职位之后立即获得了一个助理心理学家的职位，这就是我现在工作的地方。我目前在 Black Country Healthcare Trust 下属的一个名为“Action for Children”的服务机构工作，该机构覆盖斯塔福德郡地区。我再次与年轻人和儿童一起工作，我觉得与他们一起工作非常有帮助。我想，当我与年轻人一起工作时，我会反思自己小时候在心理健康方面挣扎的经历，所以我觉得这对我来说也是非常有帮助的。
for me as well um so yeah I've been working with young people to kind of support them to do kind of um evidence-based interventions and and supporting them with their well-being. And yeah, I've really enjoyed every moment of it. And I think it's just been really helpful to be able to kind of have the experience I've had and kind of give back at the same time. I love that. And actually, absolutely, like you said, there's something very different about putting your theory into practice isn't there for the first time and actually starting to do you know I'm guessing what you've been doing is one-to-one work with people and starting to do that and starting to explore
所以，我一直在与年轻人一起工作，支持他们进行循证干预，并支持他们的福祉。是的，我真的很享受其中的每一刻。我认为能够拥有我所拥有的经验，同时又能回馈社会，这非常有帮助。我喜欢这一点。而且确实，就像你说的，第一次将理论付诸实践，并开始做——我猜你一直在做的是与人们进行一对一的工作，并开始探索
the comfortability of being in a room with somebody and trying to use that time together to make a difference and that's a really wonderful experience that you were able to get even before you were doing assistant work. It sounds incredible. You were starting to make a difference and get that little buzz that we get from, you know, people saying this is working, this is making a difference. Yeah, definitely. I think it was just kind of helpful to have that first-hand experience,
与某人共处一室的舒适感，并试图利用这段时间共同做出改变，这是一种非常美妙的体验，即使在你做助理工作之前就能获得。这听起来太不可思议了。你开始做出改变，并获得那种我们从人们说“这很有用，这带来了改变”中得到的快感。是的，绝对是。我认为拥有那种第一手的经验非常有帮助，
but also kind of being able to lean into the experience and actually develop alongside because I feel like with um any kind of role where you work with someone's mental health I think you get a lot of imposter syndrome and I think for me that was a big thing especially with my first assistant post where I was thinking I do not belong I've just kind of gotten here by fluke and I think it was really helpful to to learn that actually it's okay to develop as you're working and reflect on your experiences because that's what helps to develop you as a practitioner really yeah absolutely I know that some of our audience will be like well how long did you work in that post then before you got your assistant
但同时也能够深入体验并在此过程中共同发展。因为我觉得在任何与他人心理健康相关的工作中，你都会产生很多“冒名顶替综合症”。对我来说，这尤其是在我的第一份助理工作中，当时我想“我不属于这里，我只是侥幸来到这里”。我认为学习到“在工作中发展并反思自己的经历是没问题的，因为这才是帮助你成长为一名从业者的关键”这一点非常有帮助。是的，绝对是。我知道我们的一些听众会想：“那你在那份工作中工作了多久才得到助理职位？”
post and how long after graduation did you get your assistant post can you give us a little bit of kind of time frame if that's okay yeah of course so um when I was kind of volunteering within PAWS um I was working kind of part-time alongside my undergraduate degree so I think I was working part-time I'd say probably for a year um and then I was lucky enough to kind of be employed by the same service. And I was working with them for two years part time. And I think for me, the main thing that kind of helped me when I was kind of applying for the assistant psychologist role was I had that two years of part time experience, which really equated to one full year of experience. But I think for me, what helped even more was the service I was applying to. I really was able to kind of cater my experience to that service. So having worked with young people and using intervention with young people within PAWS and then applying for an assistant role,
“毕业后多久才得到助理职位？”如果可以的话，你能给我们一个时间框架吗？当然可以。当我在 Paws 做志愿者时，我是在攻读本科学位的同时兼职工作。我想我兼职工作了大概一年，然后我很幸运被同一个服务机构聘用了。我和他们一起兼职工作了两年。对我来说，在申请助理心理学家职位时，最主要帮助我的是那两年的兼职经验，这相当于一年的全职经验。但我认为，对我帮助更大的是我申请的服务机构。我真的能够根据那个服务机构的需求来调整我的经验。因为在 Paws 与年轻人一起工作并使用干预措施，然后申请助理职位，
I was really able to kind of reflect on my experiences and how I would be able to kind of manage the differences of working within PAWS and then working within a different service and I think that really helped me definitely but you know I think one of the difficult things about counting you know whole time equivalents is that um you know I said it before in the podcast when I did my honorary post um it equated actually probably to like 10 days which isn't even half a month but because that was spread over probably three or four months the amount of learning and development and you know increasing in my confidence I was able to do within that couple of months was amazing you know and I and you know what we were saying before we began as well was that we really need to be changing and developing and reflecting and in the two-year period you're going to be a very different person
我真的能够反思我的经历，以及我将如何管理在 Paws 工作与在不同服务机构工作之间的差异。我认为这确实非常有帮助。但你知道，我认为计算“全职等效”（WTE）的一个困难之处在于，正如我在播客中之前说过的，当我做荣誉职位时，它实际上只相当于 10 天，甚至不到半个月。但因为那是分散在三四个月里的，我在那几个月里所获得的学习、成长以及自信心的提升是惊人的。你知道，正如我们在开始前所说的，我们需要不断改变、发展和反思。在两年时间里，你会成为一个非常不同的人，
even from the very extent that your brain is going to be more developed you know in terms of if you went to uni at 18 you come out at 21 by the time you're 23 your brain is almost kind of fully done-ish you know in terms of your frontal lobes and everything you're going to change if you haven't changed a great deal within those two years that would be more worrying but of course you were then because you've been talking the talk and walking the walk for two years and doing one-to-one work so even though I hear you on the imposter syndrome I would say that you were most very well qualified and experienced to be able to get that assistant post and I'm not at all surprised that you did get it. Yeah I think I think reflecting back now I do feel like I was ready at that time and I feel like it helped me to apply at the right time and I think using those reflection skills really helped
甚至从你的大脑发育程度来看，如果你 18 岁上大学，21 岁毕业，到 23 岁时，你的大脑在额叶等方面几乎已经发育完全。如果你在这两年里没有发生巨大的变化，那反而更令人担忧。但当然，你确实变了，因为你已经谈论并实践了两年，并且做了一对一的工作。所以，尽管我理解你的“冒名顶替综合症”，但我会说你非常有资格和经验去获得那个助理职位，我一点也不惊讶你得到了它。是的，我现在回想起来，我觉得我当时已经准备好了。我觉得这帮助我在正确的时间申请。我认为使用那些反思技巧确实帮助
me to think actually I do feel ready now because I was considering it for a while but I thought actually I want to get more out of this role before I do that um and it totally resonates with me around how actually even if you're working kind of once every week or like a really kind of sparse amount of time in a different role it really helps because I suppose alongside my current assistant role within Action for Children I'm also doing a role swap um with another um service so um once everynight, I go over to the autism assessment team and kind of support that team around autism assessments. And actually, although it's once a fortnight, you think, well, that's not a lot of experience. But actually just those kind of first couple of times I've done that role swap, I've actually got so much out of it that you really
我思考“实际上我现在感觉准备好了”。因为我考虑了一段时间，但我认为“在做那件事之前，我想从这个角色中获得更多”。这与我关于即使你每周只工作一次，或者在不同角色中工作时间非常少，它也非常有帮助的观点完全产生共鸣。因为我想在 Action for Children 的当前助理角色之外，我还在与另一个服务机构进行角色互换。所以，每两周一次，我会去自闭症评估团队，支持该团队进行自闭症评估。实际上，虽然是每两周一次，你可能会想“那经验不多”。但实际上，仅仅是那几次角色互换，我就收获颇丰，你真的
kind of value that time and it's not kind of the quantity but the quality of what what you're learning and what you're developing that really helps. That sounds brilliant have you sorted that out yourself informally or is that something that was offered to you? Um so I'd never heard of a role swap before um and my supervisor kind of introduced me to the idea of it. So I'm doing it within the same trust that I'm working in. So what we did is we have a kind of assistant psychologist group within the trust. And I kind of approached someone who was in another service that I wanted to kind of get some more experience in. And our supervisors kind of met with us and we kind of drew up a bit of a contract just to formalize things so um you know I'm getting kind of experience in her service and she's getting
会珍惜那段时间。这不在于数量，而在于你所学到的和发展的质量，这真的很有帮助。这听起来太棒了。你是自己非正式地安排的，还是别人提供给你的？我以前从未听说过角色互换，我的主管向我介绍了这个想法。所以，我是在我工作的同一个信托机构内进行的。我们所做的是，我们在信托机构内有一个助理心理学家小组。我联系了另一个我想获得更多经验的服务机构里的人。我们的主管见了面，我们起草了一份合同，把事情正式化了。所以，
experience in mine and we're kind of supporting each other while still being in the same role that we're in so it's kind of having that comfort of being in the same service but still getting more experience which I didn't know existed but it's great I absolutely love that and that's making me a little bit misty-eyed as well because in the aspiring psychologist collective I talk about when I was an aspiring psychologist and I came up with this idea of the assistant psychologist skills exchange which is basically what you're saying you know you hang out with other people and kind of do their job with them but actually you're swapping which is even better because then you kind of have to kind of get on and do it and i think like you said you know when you're
我在她的服务机构获得经验，她在我的服务机构获得经验。我们互相支持，同时仍然保持我们各自的角色。所以，这既有在同一个服务机构工作的舒适感，又能获得更多经验，我以前不知道还有这种方式，但这太棒了。我绝对喜欢这个主意，这让我有点热泪盈眶。因为在“Aspiring Psychologist Collective”中，我谈到当我还是一个有志心理学家时，我想出了“助理心理学家技能交换”的想法，这基本上就是你所说的。你和其他人在一起，做他们的工作，但实际上你们是在交换，这更好，因为这样你必须去上手做。而且我认为，就像你说的，当你
doing something once a fortnight still that's twice a month you can still learn so much um and it just gives you you know it thickens your narrative in that area of work so that it's another tip you know because what we're looking at generally not necessarily the people who are employing you but we feel like when we're aspiring so which is we kind of want to do you want to tick off older adults you want to tick off you know children and young people who want to tick off you know intellectual learning disabilities and um you know autism and you know it gives you another thing that just helps you feel like you've got less Achilles heels you know so we absolutely go to training
每两周做一次某事，那仍然是一个月两次，你仍然可以学到很多。它丰富了你在该工作领域的叙事，这是另一个小贴士。因为我们通常关注的——不一定是雇佣你的人，而是我们作为有志心理学家时——我们想勾选老年人、儿童和年轻人、智力障碍、自闭症等领域。它给了你另一个东西，帮助你感觉自己的“阿喀琉斯之踵”更少了。所以我们绝对会去训练，
with Achilles heels with things that we know we need to learn and shape and develop and everything should be shaped and developed during training but you know for you to feel like you are you've earned your stripes enough to be there I think that's really really useful yeah definitely and I think I'm really lucky that I'm in a post right now. I've been in the post for over a year and my contract keeps getting extended, thankfully. But, yeah, it's nice to not kind of be in that position where I have to leave to get more experience. Because I think sometimes when you're enjoying an AP job and you have that ability to kind of stay there, actually, it's nice to explore those different options without having to leave where you're currently at and I think that's a really nice way to get experience and understand what what you
带着阿喀琉斯之踵，带着我们知道需要学习、塑造和发展的东西。一切都应该在训练期间得到塑造和发展。但对于你来说，感觉自己已经赢得了足够的资历去那里，我认为这真的非常有帮助。是的，绝对是。我很幸运现在有一个职位。我已经在这个职位上工作了一年多了，幸运的是我的合同一直在续签。但是，不用为了获得更多经验而离开，这种感觉真好。因为我认为有时当你享受一份助理心理学家工作，并且有能力留下来时，能够探索那些不同的选择而不必离开你当前的地方，这真的很好。我认为这是一种获得经验并了解你
enjoy doing and and as well as the tick box kind of getting that experience just from finding out what what you enjoy in terms of when you're working as well so that's been nice that is brilliant and actually what you get to do is you get to deepen your relationships with the team you're working in and with your supervisor and managerial staff, too, because it can feel a little bit like treadmill-y, can't it? With, you know, people just coming on to a role and then dropping off. But I having your staff be able to think deeper and, you know, more holistically about the clients and services you're working with. So I would urge you to think about whether you might be able to do. I've forgotten what it's called. Role swap, was it? Yeah.
喜欢做什么的非常好的方式，除了勾选经验框之外，还能发现你在工作中喜欢什么。所以这很不错。这太棒了。实际上，你所能做的是加深你与所在团队、主管和管理人员的关系。因为这可能会让人感觉有点像在跑步机上，不是吗？人们刚进入一个角色，然后又离开。但让你的员工能够更深入、更全面地思考客户和服务，这很好。所以我敦促你考虑是否可以做——我忘了它叫什么了——角色互换，是吗？是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Role swap within your service because it's going to bring value to your service even you know you seeing the way that they set up you know referrals assessments you know talking about team meetings and stuff all of that if you see something that's working well in practice for another service you're more likely to bring that back and that might lead to to rich improvements for your own service too yeah definitely and i think especially at the beginning we've been kind of supporting each other so I'd role swap and um the other girl in the other service would support me in the role so
是的，在你的服务机构内进行角色互换，因为它会为你的服务机构带来价值。即使是你看到他们设置转诊、评估、讨论团队会议等方式，如果你看到其他服务机构在实践中运作良好的东西，你更有可能将其带回来，这可能会为你的服务机构带来丰富的改进。是的，绝对是。而且我认为特别是在开始时，我们一直在互相支持。所以我进行角色互换，
it's not like you're completely in a new a new place you're kind of being supported and then slowly you can kind of just do the swap completely and I think that can kind of help you feel more supported as well but I do think it's really helpful and I'm glad I got to know about it so hopefully other people can kind of explore that option as well yeah thank you well done to your supervisor hats off to them um I'm very excited about that and I know there'll be lots of little ears listening to this going oh that sounds good um because I was talking just on a on a live yesterday when you get that feeling that you've plateaued and you're like oh oh, no, I'm going to have to start looking for other jobs.
另一个服务机构的女孩会在那个角色中支持我。所以这不像你完全在一个新的地方，你是在被支持，然后慢慢地你可以完全进行互换。我认为这可以帮助你感到更受支持。但我确实认为这非常有帮助，我很高兴我了解到了它，希望其他人也能探索这个选择。是的，谢谢。做得好，向你的主管致敬。我对这个想法感到非常兴奋，我知道会有很多小耳朵在听这个，心想“哦，这听起来不错”。因为我昨天在直播中谈到，当你感到自己进入了平台期，心想“哦，不，我得开始找其他工作了”。
But maybe this is a way around that, you know. So thank you so much. Right. So we're thinking about culture and faith. Could you tell us a little bit for anybody who doesn't know about Islam? Could you tell us a little bit about what it involves and perhaps how you slot it into your life before we then begin to think about values um so yeah as a Muslim I feel like everybody kind of has their own kind of connection with faith and I think I feel like um Islam is is a religion but it's also a way of life so I'd say that actually when when we're thinking about Islam it's kind of we have our kind of core beliefs, which is the kind of faith in God and believe in what God has revealed to us and live in our life according to what God's ordered for us and what God wants us to do. But I think a big part of that is actually it supports your way of life.
但也许这是一个解决办法。所以非常感谢。好了，我们来谈谈文化和信仰。对于任何不了解伊斯兰教的人，你能简单介绍一下它涉及什么，以及在你开始思考价值观之前，你是如何将其融入生活的吗？是的，作为一名穆斯林，我觉得每个人都有自己与信仰的联系。我觉得伊斯兰教不仅是一种宗教，也是一种生活方式。所以我会说，当我们思考伊斯兰教时，我们有核心信仰，即对上帝的信仰，相信上帝向我们启示的内容，并按照上帝为我们制定的、上帝希望我们做的方式生活。但我认为其中很大一部分是它支持你的生活方式。
So it's not just us thinking that actually it's loads of rules and it's loads of things to abide by, but actually it's things that kind of enrich your life. And I think the main kind of value and belief that I feel like is important within being a Muslim is having that faith and actually understanding that when kind of we struggle with things or when things become hard, these are things that kind of strengthen our beliefs as a Muslim, but also kind of help us to kind of persevere and help us to kind of get, but help us to kind of get through difficult times. So I suppose when we're talking about being a Muslim, I feel like it's, it can mean we can be on different journeys as a Muslim. And I feel like it's all about reconnecting to our faith.
所以我们不仅仅认为它是一堆规则和必须遵守的事情，实际上它们是丰富你生活的东西。我认为作为穆斯林，我觉得重要的主要价值观和信仰是拥有那种信仰，并真正理解当我们与事物斗争或事情变得困难时，这些是作为穆斯林加强我们信仰的事情，同时也帮助我们坚持下去，帮助我们度过困难时期。所以，当我们谈论作为一名穆斯林时，我觉得我们可以处于不同的旅程中。我觉得这完全是关于重新连接我们的信仰。
So when we're talking about values, I feel like that's incredibly important as a Muslim, because as Muslim, as Muslims, we kind of have certain values that we kind of live our lives by but also personal values so when we're thinking about kind of what it means to be a muslim um we kind of think about kind of our faith and and what what god wants from us as human beings but also kind of how we can kind of live our life by our values and do those things as well brilliant thank you so much for that so we've spoken about values now would be a good chance to introduce the values that we've gone through and you've selected for today so um we thought it'd be better to do this bit the bit before off camera because otherwise it's like uh what is that bit again what what um so yeah we okay so the first of our values is acceptance to be open to and allowing of things I dislike or don't want in myself others and the world
所以当我们谈论价值观时，我觉得作为一名穆斯林，这极其重要。因为作为穆斯林，我们有某些我们赖以生存的价值观，也有个人价值观。所以当我们思考作为一名穆斯林意味着什么时，我们思考我们的信仰，以及上帝作为人类对我们的要求，同时也思考我们如何按照我们的价值观生活，并做这些事情。太棒了，非常感谢。我们已经谈到了价值观，现在是一个很好的机会来介绍我们今天挑选的价值观。我们认为在镜头外先做这一部分会更好，否则就像“那部分是什么来着？”所以，好的，我们的第一个价值观是“接纳”：对我在自己、他人和周围世界中不喜欢或不想要的事物保持开放和允许。
around me how that sings out to you and how it's important for you um both in terms of your faith culture and your work yeah so I think um acceptance is a value that I feel like I've started to live by I feel like when we're living our life by our values we can kind of um wane in terms of going back and forth in terms of actually being able to live by our values but I feel like acceptance is a core value for me in in terms of faith I feel like when difficult things um when we experience difficult things and hard things happen um as a Muslim I feel like actually we we kind of feel that these experiences are our tests from god and actually that they're to kind of help us to kind of move forward in life
这如何引起你的共鸣，以及它在你的信仰、文化和工作中为何重要？是的，我认为接纳是我开始赖以生存的一种价值观。我觉得当我们按照价值观生活时，我们在能够按照价值观生活方面可能会有起伏。但我认为接纳是我信仰中的核心价值观。我觉得当困难的事情发生时，作为一名穆斯林，我们觉得这些经历是上帝对我们的考验，实际上它们是为了帮助我们在生活中前进。
and actually when difficulty kind of falls on us that actually being able to accept what's happened helps you to kind of move on from that um and I feel like it's a big thing with me in terms of my own mental health and and accepting my own experiences um because I feel like there was a time where I might have been kind of challenging how I'd been feeling and wanting to forget things or push them away and I found that the more that I was pushing my experiences away the more that I was struggling with them and actually having that acceptance of things happen for a reason and and actually being able to move on from that has really helped me um but I also feel like it's kind of helped me in my professional career as well so I feel like um there was a time where if I experienced kind of
当困难降临时，能够接纳所发生的事情有助于你从中走出来。我觉得这对我自己的心理健康和接纳我自己的经历来说是一件大事。因为我觉得曾经有一段时间，我可能会挑战我的感受，想要忘记事情或把它们推开。我发现我越是推开我的经历，我就越是在挣扎。实际上，接纳事情发生是有原因的，并且能够从中走出来，这真的帮助了我。但我还觉得它在我的职业生涯中也帮助了我。我觉得曾经有一段时间，如果我经历了一种
a rejection that I would take that very personally and I'd kind of really reflect badly on myself and have a lot of feelings of shame and and just feeling like I'm not good enough um and I know I've I've kind of applied for the doctorate course before and and I know that's something that others might have experienced of where you feel where if your application isn't accepted or if you don't get that job or if you don't kind of if things don't pan out the way that we want them to pan out we really take hold that personally and and we get hung up on it um and I feel when we're able to kind of be more accepting of changes and and I think that's something that I found that
拒绝，我会非常个人化地对待它，我会对自己进行非常糟糕的反思，并产生很多羞耻感，感觉自己不够好。我知道我之前申请过博士课程，我知道其他人可能也经历过这种情况：如果你的申请没有被接受，或者你没有得到那份工作，或者事情没有按照我们想要的方式发展，我们真的会非常个人化地对待它，并对此耿耿于怀。我觉得当我们能够对变化更加接纳时，
when I've been more accepting of changes it's helped me to kind of move on and reflect on things and thinking about actually what's kind of led me to this point or how can I move on from this and I think previously I was very goal-based when I was thinking about my career so I was very like I need to get an assistant job and then I need to get onto the course and it's all time limited and if it doesn't happen I don't know what I'm going to do um but when I started to be more accepting um I found that actually I found more enjoyment in things I found that actually I could enjoy my assistant job a lot more because I was spending time enjoying my experiences rather than thinking about what's next um so that's helped me, I think. Good. Good. Really big pleased to hear that.
当我对比变化更加接纳时，它帮助我从中走出来并反思事情，思考是什么导致我走到这一步，或者我如何能从中走出来。以前我在思考职业时非常以目标为导向，我非常需要得到一份助理工作，然后需要进入课程，这一切都是有时限的，如果没发生，我不知道该怎么办。但当我开始更加接纳时，我发现我在事情中找到了更多的乐趣。我发现我能更享受我的助理工作，因为我花时间享受我的经历，而不是思考下一步是什么。所以这对我很有帮助。好，很高兴听到这个。
And, yeah, it's about being able to look sideways as well, isn't it? Not just forwards. And some really important, really important points you've raised there. All right. Thank you. So the second of our values is persistence to continue resolutely with your task or challenge, despite problems, fears and difficulties. Yeah, so I feel like that does relate to a little bit of what I've talked about in terms of acceptance. But I feel like we all kind of go through things in our life where we struggle and I think when I've kind of thought about back to my experiences I feel like there was a time where I might have struggled with persistence where I've tried to persist and and I felt that actually I wasn't able to live my life according to that value but actually how when I was able to persist and when I was able to kind of show persistence how how effective that
而且，这也要能够向侧面看，不是吗？不仅仅是向前看。你提出了非常重要、非常重要的观点。好的，谢谢。我们的第二个价值观是“坚持”：尽管有困难、恐惧和阻碍，仍坚定地继续你的任务或挑战。是的，我觉得这确实与我谈到的关于接纳的内容有一点联系。但我认为我们生活中都会经历挣扎。当我回想我的经历时，我觉得曾经有一段时间我可能在坚持方面挣扎，我试图坚持，但我感到我无法按照那个价值观生活。但实际上，当我能够坚持，当我能够表现出坚持时，它是多么有效。
was for me so I know when I was struggling with my mental health I I really struggled to kind of move forward and and to to go forward with things and I think when I had that ability to persist it really kind of bettered me as a person not only just how I was feeling but kind of made me more um I feel resilient as a person um and I think it's something that I try to move forward in in my general life when things kind of are difficult I feel like sometimes I can find it difficult and I might want to give up but then I when I do persist I'm grateful that I have um and I think everybody who's listening would have times in their life where where they've felt that
我知道当我与心理健康作斗争时，我真的很难前进。当我拥有那种坚持的能力时，它真的让我作为一个人的素质得到了提升，不仅是我的感受，而且让我作为一个人的韧性更强。我认为这是我尝试在日常生活中前进的东西。当事情变得困难时，我觉得有时我会发现很难，我可能会想放弃。但当我坚持下去时，我很感激我做到了。我认为每个收听的人在生活中都会有感到
they've kind of experienced something that was really difficult whether have times in their life where where they've felt that they've kind of experienced something that was really difficult whether that be in their personal life or professional um and i think with psychology it is one of those kind of careers where persistence is really important um we know actually it is a competitive kind of place but actually how when we do persist we can see those rewards and I think just persisting in in what we want to do in our career can be really helpful um and kind of moving forward with the steps and even if you do receive news that isn't what what you wanted to hear of being able to kind of move forward from that shows that persistence um so yeah I do feel like we reflect that as
他们经历了一些非常困难的事情的时候，无论是在个人生活还是职业生活中。我认为在心理学领域，这是一个坚持非常重要的职业。我们知道它确实是一个竞争激烈的领域，但当我们坚持下去时，我们可以看到那些回报。我认为仅仅坚持我们想做的事情在我们的职业生涯中非常有帮助。在职业生涯中不断前进，即使你收到的消息不是你想听到的，能够从中走出来也展现了那种坚持。所以，是的，我确实觉得我们作为
psychologists definitely and is there some crossover with your faith in terms of persistence as well what does your faith teach us about persistence for example yeah so I think it's in Islam there there's a concept called sabr which is basically meaning that when we go through things that are difficult or when we go through trials and tribulations that when we show persistence and we're able to kind of move forward with things that actually we're rewarded for that and we're able to kind of get benefits from that and I think it's very much about we do as much as we can to change the situation and move forward but in cases where we've done our best and we can't
心理学家反映了这一点。你的信仰中是否有关于坚持的交叉点？例如，你的信仰教导我们关于坚持的什么？是的，我认为在伊斯兰教中有一个概念叫“Sabr”（坚忍），基本上意味着当我们经历困难的事情或经历考验和磨难时，当我们表现出坚持并能够继续前进时，我们实际上会因此得到回报，并能从中获得益处。我认为这很大程度上在于我们尽我们所能去改变现状并前进，但在我们已经尽力而无法
kind of change a situation it's about kind of keeping faith thinking that actually things will get better and showing that kind of ability to move forward when we can and when things aren't when we're not able to move forward actually keeping faith helps us to stay grounded and move forward in our lives thank you for that um as we were talking about persistence before off camera we also thought about the other value of patience so now might be an interesting and useful time to think about the value of patience um which is might be versus persistence or in addition to persistence yeah so i think i was touching on it a little bit towards the end it kind of veered
改变现状的情况下，这在于保持信仰，认为事情会好转，并展现出那种在我们可以时继续前进的能力。当事情无法改变时，保持信仰有助于我们保持脚踏实地，并在生活中继续前进。谢谢。当我们之前在镜头外谈论坚持时，我们也想到了“耐心”这个价值观。所以现在可能是一个有趣且有用的时间来思考“耐心”这个价值观，它可能与坚持相对，或者作为坚持的补充。是的，我想我在最后稍微提到了它，它有点偏离了。
into patience where actually we think about we always kind of persist and push forward but there are points where sometimes the best thing that we can do is be patient and actually um something like acceptance commitment therapy really sits well with me because I feel like we change what we can change and what is in our control but when we um when we're struggling and actually there isn't anything that we can do it is about kind of accepting that and being patient and kind of thinking about actually there isn't anything that I can do to change the situations how do I move forward from here um and when I was talking about persistence in in relation to being a, I feel that patience is really important because we know when we wait and when we keep faith,
进入耐心，实际上我们认为我们总是坚持不懈、勇往直前，但有时我们能做的最好的事情就是保持耐心。实际上，像接纳承诺疗法（ACT）就很适合我，因为我觉得我们可以改变我们能改变的、在掌控之中的事情，但当我们挣扎且确实无能为力时，关键在于接纳并保持耐心，思考实际上我无法改变现状，我该如何从这里继续前进。当我谈到与坚持相关的毅力时，我觉得耐心非常重要，因为我们知道，当我们等待并保持信念时，
that actually it can be really, really helpful to us as people to understand that sometimes things aren't in our control. But what we can do is be patient and kind of persevere and move forward with things. And I think within psychology, you have to be a bit patient and and i know it's one thing that i learned when i did my first uh deacon application um i didn't realize how patient i'd have to be in terms of finding out when you get if you get accepted if you get an interview it's a long time to to wait but you definitely show that patience to be able to kind of wait through um and and persist and kind of spend that time to to do that absolutely the struggle is real it goes on a long time yeah oh and anybody else who's but you know by the time
实际上，作为一个人，理解有时事情并不在我们的掌控之中，这真的非常有帮助。但我们能做的是保持耐心，坚持不懈，继续前进。我认为在心理学领域，你必须要有耐心。我知道这是我在第一次申请临床心理学博士（DClinPsy）时学到的一件事，我没意识到在等待录取结果、等待面试通知时需要那么大的耐心，等待的时间很长，但你确实表现出了那种耐心，能够坚持等待并投入时间去做这件事。绝对是这样，这种挣扎是真实的，而且持续了很长时间。是的，哦，还有其他任何人，但你知道，到
this episode goes out i think we will just be on the cusp of submissions um for this year so the waiting game um begins so yeah we will come back to that in future as well thank you Alicia so the next is curiosity to be curious open-minded and interested eager to explore discover and learn yeah so I think um as Muslim, we're always encouraged to be curious. So it's always about kind of seeking knowledge and being curious about what you believe as well. So when we are kind of reconnecting to our faith or connecting to our faith, we want to be able to be curious about what our faith means, what our faith means to us. And we're encouraged to kind of seek knowledge and and develop um so it's not about us just saying actually this is what you
这一集播出时，我想我们刚好处于今年提交申请的临界点，所以等待的游戏开始了。所以，是的，我们以后也会回到这个话题。谢谢你，Alicia。下一个是好奇心，要保持好奇、思想开放、感兴趣，渴望探索、发现和学习。是的，所以我认为，作为穆斯林，我们总是被鼓励保持好奇。所以这总是关于寻求知识，以及对你的信仰保持好奇。因此，当我们重新与信仰建立联系或与信仰连接时，我们希望能够对我们的信仰意味着什么、我们的信仰对我们意味着什么感到好奇。我们被鼓励去寻求知识和发展，所以这不仅仅是我们说，实际上这就是你
believe and and that's it but we always are encouraged to kind of go further and seek more knowledge and and think about how that relates to us um and I feel like curiosity for me as as a person is really important as well um because I feel like curiosity kind of opens the doors to being open-minded so when we're curious about things we can be more accepting we can kind of be um more tolerant and and things like that so I feel like within um my experience within psychology being curious has really helped me because I feel like I when reflecting back on previous experiences sometimes I could have been quite rigid-minded and thinking actually trying to fit people into a formulation rather than the other way around
所相信的，仅此而已，我们总是被鼓励去更进一步，寻求更多的知识，并思考它与我们有什么关系。我觉得好奇心对我个人来说也非常重要，因为我觉得好奇心打开了思想开放的大门，所以当我们对事物感到好奇时，我们可以变得更具包容性，我们可以变得更宽容等等。所以我感觉在我的心理学经验中，保持好奇心真的帮助了我，因为我觉得当我回顾过去的经历时，有时我的思想可能相当僵化，试图把人硬塞进一个公式里，而不是反过来。
and I think when we're curious and when we kind of keep an open mind and we kind of question things we can really consider like a whole situation and things and how to best support someone but also how we can kind of move forward with our own career so when we're kind of curious about what we enjoy what we find helpful it helps us to develop as as a psychologist but also kind of develop what we want to do going forward brilliant thank you so much for that one and next one is contribution to contribute give help assist share or be generous yeah so um i feel like my journey within psychology kind of started on me reflecting on wanting to contribute and share my experience or share the share what I've learned from my
我认为当我们保持好奇，保持开放的心态，并质疑事物时，我们才能真正考虑整个情况以及如何最好地支持某人，同时也考虑我们如何推动自己的职业生涯。所以当我们对我们喜欢什么、我们觉得什么有帮助感到好奇时，它有助于我们作为心理学家发展，也有助于我们发展未来想做的事情。太棒了，非常感谢你分享这一点。下一个是贡献，即贡献、给予、帮助、协助、分享或慷慨。是的，所以我感觉我在心理学领域的旅程始于我反思想要贡献和分享我的经验，或者分享我从我的
experiences with people so being able to kind of support other people with their own mental health and I think for for many of the um aspiring psychologists or psychologists that would be similar in in wanting to help people and and make a contribution and and I do feel like it's a it's um a profession which is really rewarding which is which is amazing um and I feel like that kind of extends in into kind of faith and and me as a Muslim because I feel like as as a Muslim we're kind of encouraged to to contribute so we're encouraged to kind of give charity help others and and support people um so actually when when I'm working as an assistant psychologist I feel like I'm living my life as uh as per my values not only as a person and as as like um as a psychologist but
经历中学到的东西。能够支持他人的心理健康，我认为对于许多有抱负的心理学家或心理学家来说，想要帮助他人并做出贡献的想法是相似的。我确实觉得这是一个非常有意义的职业，这太棒了。而且我觉得这种贡献延伸到了信仰中，作为一名穆斯林，因为我觉得作为穆斯林，我们被鼓励去贡献，我们被鼓励去施舍、帮助他人并支持人们。所以实际上，当我作为助理心理学家工作时，我觉得我正在按照我的价值观生活，不仅是作为一个人和一名心理学家，而且
also kind of as a Muslim and being able to give back to people which is really rewarding for me it must feel like double bubble like I often say I've got the best job in the world but if you're also like singing from your hymn sheet for your for your faith as well as well as your own personal and professional kind of passions it must just feel so I don't know uplifting energizing all of those good terms yeah definitely I feel like when you work in a in a profession where you're also able to reconnect to your values but also to your faith it does feel like that it feels like a double reward um because I feel like when I'm supporting other people to live life by their values it also
也是作为一名穆斯林，能够回馈他人，这对我来说非常有意义。这一定感觉像是双重收获，我经常说我拥有世界上最好的工作，但如果你同时也在为你的信仰以及你个人的职业热情而歌唱，那一定感觉非常振奋、充满活力，所有这些好的词汇。是的，绝对是这样。我觉得当你从事一份职业，同时也能重新与你的价值观和信仰建立联系时，确实感觉如此。这感觉像是一种双重奖励，因为我觉得当我支持他人按照他们的价值观生活时，它也
helps me to reflect on my values and and what's important to me um and then it's almost like a kind of that thing where you practice where you preach and I think sometimes as as psychologists we can sometimes give the best advice and not take that advice ourselves and I think sometimes as a psychologist we can sometimes give the best advice and not take that advice ourselves and I feel like that's something that's been really important to me is is being able to relate the things that I use in practice to my own life as well um yeah which I feel like has made me a better psychologist as well as a better person I think absolutely there's a recent episode I did about you know using our own skills to kind of navigate our own mental health and once we start to do that it's not it's not
帮助我反思我的价值观以及对我来说什么才是重要的。这几乎就像是你践行你所宣扬的东西。我认为有时作为心理学家，我们能给出最好的建议，却不一定能自己采纳。我觉得对我来说非常重要的一点是，能够将我在实践中使用的东西与我自己的生活联系起来。是的，我觉得这让我成为了一名更好的心理学家，也成为了一个更好的人。我认为绝对是这样。我最近做了一集关于利用我们自己的技能来应对我们自己的心理健康的节目，一旦我们开始这样做，这并不是什么
rocket science is it you know when the stuff we're saying is brilliant when we actually use it we do feel better you know of course we should be doing it and we should make time for it so yeah I totally agree and the last of our identified values is compassion to be acting kindly towards ourselves and or others when in pain um yeah so I feel like um I I've always been quite compassionate towards other people and I feel like um kind of choosing psychology as a career kind of helped me to live my life according to being compassionate I feel like one of the things that I've always struggled with is is using that compassion towards myself and I feel like that's a very hard thing to do um but when we are able to do it and we're able to build those skills it makes things so much better and it makes you be able to reflect on things so much better so
火箭科学，对吧？你知道，当我们真正使用我们所说的那些精彩的东西时，我们确实感觉更好。你知道，当然我们应该这样做，我们应该为此腾出时间。所以我完全同意。我们确定的最后一个价值观是同情心，即在痛苦时对自己和/或他人表现出友善。是的，所以我感觉我一直对他人相当有同情心，而且我觉得选择心理学作为职业帮助我按照同情心来生活。我觉得我一直挣扎的一件事是对自己使用这种同情心，我觉得这是一件非常困难的事情。但当我们能够做到这一点，并且能够建立这些技能时，它会让事情变得好得多，也会让你能够更好地反思事物。所以
I feel like when when I am able to be more self-compassionate um i do feel like i get more reward out of things because actually i feel like sometimes we can be quite hard on ourselves um and we live life according to our values in terms of showing compassion to other people um but sometimes don't apply those same values to ourselves um and i think that can be really really important um so yeah I think that has helped incredibly I think it really can and I know I keep saying about all the stuff that happens off camera and people are like why can we listen to the off camera sounds great one of the least downloaded episodes of this podcast series is the one on kind of self-compassion and actually
我觉得当我能够对自己更加慈悲时，我确实觉得我从事情中获得了更多的回报，因为实际上我觉得有时我们对自己太苛刻了。我们按照对他人的同情心来生活，但有时却不把同样的价值观应用到自己身上。我认为这可能非常非常重要。所以是的，我认为这非常有帮助。我认为确实如此。我知道我一直在说镜头外发生的所有事情，人们会问为什么我们不能听到镜头外的声音，听起来很棒。这个播客系列中下载量最少的剧集之一就是关于自我同情的，实际上
that's the the one that's going to be the difference that makes a difference so everybody download that one as well because you're so right it's so important um just before we finish because i'm aware of the time um i picked up a couple of values that i thought might be useful for us to kind of talk to as one point really really based on my observations of having worked in a central birmingham service with people um who um who follow islam and um and i guess you know going to friday prayers and for the male members of the staff i don't know if it's open to women yet i'm not sure perhaps culturally naive of me to admit that but at the time when i was there it was it was males only for friday
那才是真正能带来改变的关键。所以大家都去下载那一集，因为你是对的，这太重要了。在结束之前，因为我知道时间的关系，我挑选了几个我认为对我们讨论有用的价值观。这完全基于我在伯明翰中心服务机构工作的观察，那里的人们信奉伊斯兰教。我猜你知道，去参加周五的祈祷，对于男性员工来说，我不知道它是否对女性开放，我不确定，也许承认这一点在文化上显得我很天真，但在我当时在那里的时候，周五祈祷只有男性参加。
prayers and stopping and having prayer rooms and things like that. And also for people not watching on YouTube, you're a hijab wearer. And so, you know, I'm aware that, you know, there's different thoughts and feelings and expectations of people accessing services about, I guess, a number of factors that not always that are not always nice you know to be to be blunt about that and I guess I was thinking about assertiveness respect flexibility and freedom you know so to other people to have freedom of choice and actions but also being respectful and your perhaps assertiveness to be able to stop and say actually I do need to stop now because I need to do this or I can't do that because that's outside of what I what I'm what I believe or what I feel comfortable with um but also whether there's any room for flexibility around some of this
祈祷和停下来使用祈祷室等等。而且对于不在YouTube上观看的人，你戴着头巾。所以，我知道人们在获取服务时有不同的想法、感受和期望，关于我猜的一些因素，坦率地说，并不总是那么令人愉快。我当时在想果断、尊重、灵活性和自由，你知道，给他人选择和行动的自由，但也保持尊重。你也许需要果断，能够停下来并说，实际上我现在需要停下来，因为我需要做这个，或者我不能做那个，因为那超出了我的信仰或我感到舒适的范围。但也要考虑在这些方面是否有灵活性的空间。
is it okay to have a brief conversation about some of that Leisha? Yeah that sounds like a good conversation um I feel like one of the things to kind of point out is I definitely feel like there are rules with all religions and all kind of cultures, I feel like as well. So I feel like we all kind of have points of assertiveness and things that we kind of morally want to want to do or believe. And I feel like that's kind of exists in all of us. And I think when we're thinking about religion, I feel like it's really important to think, yeah, there's definitely things that we should do and things that we shouldn't do in terms of what we believe as Muslims. And I feel like when we're thinking about assertiveness, I suppose the reason that we do it is because of our devotion to what we've been told by God and what's been instructed by us by God and I think when we're thinking about assertiveness as well I think it's it's helpful to think about things in terms of we have that kind of trust and and belief that the things that have been kind of um that have been decreed to us and the things that we are told to do help us to live a better life
关于其中的一些内容进行简短的交谈可以吗，Leisha？是的，这听起来像是一个很好的对话。我觉得有一点需要指出，我绝对觉得所有的宗教和文化都有规则。我觉得我们都有果断的时刻，以及我们在道德上想要做或相信的事情。我觉得这存在于我们所有人之中。我认为当我们思考宗教时，我觉得思考这一点非常重要：是的，作为穆斯林，在我们所信仰的范围内，确实有些事情我们应该做，有些事情我们不应该做。当我们思考果断时，我想我们这样做的原因是因为我们对上帝告诉我们的事情以及上帝指示我们的事情的虔诚。我认为当我们思考果断时，我认为从我们拥有那种信任和信念的角度来思考是有帮助的，即那些被规定给我们的事情，以及被告知要做的事情，能帮助我们过上更好的生活。
and and actually when we're thinking about um being a muslim and we think about kind of giving charity and that's something that's ordained on us and and fasting to kind of um consider um people who are less fortunate and all those kind of things it helps you to reflect on on yourself as a person but helps you to live a life according to your values and helps you to kind of live as a better person and I suppose we have that belief that God knows better than us and I suppose sometimes our kind of desires or the things that we want to do might kind of go against our values and and it's thinking about how we can live our life according to our values and and even if we do things that we're not supposed
实际上，当我们思考作为一名穆斯林，思考施舍，这是我们必须做的，还有斋戒，以考虑那些不幸的人，所有这些事情都有助于你反思自己作为一个人的身份，但也有助于你按照你的价值观生活，并帮助你成为一个更好的人。我想我们有这样的信念，即上帝比我们更了解。我想有时我们的欲望或我们想做的事情可能会违背我们的价值观，所以关键在于思考我们如何能够按照我们的价值观生活，即使我们做了我们不应该做的事情，
to do or doing things that kind of take us away from our values I think a big thing within Islam is being able to notice that and then seeking forgiveness for it but then kind of going back to living our life by our values so I feel like sometimes when we're thinking about things, it's about how actually, we know that we all kind of at points in our lives, go move away from our values. But the important part is, is kind of noticing that and coming back because we know nobody's perfect. And it's hard when we kind of hold ourselves to perfection. But when we understand that actually, as humans, we aren't perfect perfect and we can't do things all the time, then we're more likely to kind of reflect on on ourselves and then being able to live our life by our values more. And I feel like that's where kind of forgiveness kind of comes in, but also freedom as well.
或者做了让我们偏离价值观的事情，我认为伊斯兰教中很重要的一点是能够意识到这一点，然后寻求宽恕，然后回到按照我们的价值观生活。所以我感觉有时当我们思考这些事情时，关键在于我们实际上知道我们所有人都在人生的某些时刻偏离了我们的价值观。但重要的部分是意识到这一点并回归，因为我们知道没有人是完美的。当我们试图追求完美时，这很难。但当我们理解实际上作为人类，我们并不完美，我们不能一直做对所有事情时，我们就更有可能反思自己，从而能够更多地按照我们的价值观生活。我觉得这就是宽恕发挥作用的地方，自由也是如此。
We believe that everybody has the freedom to choice. Everybody has the freedom to believe so everybody has a freedom to believe what they want to believe and there's no kind of um force or there's no kind of compulsion within religion so you are kind of held accountable for what you do but if if you don't if you don't believe in islam or if you don't kind of believe in those things you have a freedom to do that but i suppose that's that's then your kind of responsibility, but it doesn't mean that you don't have the freedom to kind of choose.
我们相信每个人都有选择的自由。每个人都有信仰的自由，所以每个人都有自由去相信他们想相信的东西，宗教中没有强迫。所以你对你所做的事情负责，但如果你不相信伊斯兰教，或者如果你不相信那些事情，你有自由这样做，但我认为那是你自己的责任，但这并不意味着你没有选择的自由。
And yeah, I think that then ties into respect. And I think a big thing that we're taught is respecting people despite their differences. So no matter what your kind of religion or culture, that actually we should treat people with respect respecting people despite their differences. So no matter what your kind of religion or culture, that actually we should treat people with respect and kindness. And that's something that I suppose when you kind of look at the life of the Prophet, peace be upon him, he kind of showed that within his life work. And I think we kind of take our role models, how we should be living as Muslims
是的，我认为这与尊重有关。我认为我们被教导的一件大事是尊重他人，尽管他们存在差异。所以无论你的宗教或文化是什么，实际上我们都应该以尊重和友善对待他人。这是我在回顾先知（愿主福安之）的生活时，他在他的生活工作中展现了这一点。我认为我们从先知那里汲取我们的榜样，即我们作为穆斯林应该如何生活，
and what our values should be from from the prophet and that's how we kind of aim to live our lives um so yeah I feel like that might have touched upon uh the different parts but I think from my reflections as a Muslim that's what what I would believe um but yeah brilliant thank you and thank you for also mentioning fasting because that's a very big and important part um of your faith and something that you know I've supported clients through as well and I always from my perspective it I feel like I would dread that time of the year but actually all of the clients I've worked with love it you know they find it really energizing they find it a really nice time to come together
我们的价值观应该是什么，这就是我们旨在生活的方式。所以是的，我觉得这可能触及了不同的部分，但我认为从我作为穆斯林的思考来看，这就是我相信的。但是的，太棒了，谢谢你。也谢谢你提到斋戒，因为那是你信仰中非常重要的一部分，也是我曾经支持客户度过的一部分。从我的角度来看，我曾经会害怕那一年的那个时候，但实际上我合作过的所有客户都喜欢它，他们觉得这非常令人振奋，他们觉得这是一个聚在一起的好时光。
with their families in their community um and they really feel that it's a privilege and they really enjoy it and benefit from it yeah definitely and and i think when you when you think about fasting everyone's thinking oh you can't eat and drink for a really long time and and that's true and i think when we think about ramadan it's more than in than just fasting so i suppose when we're in Ramadan, it's a time of reflection and reconnecting to faith. And I feel like that's a time where we kind of remove distractions. So we try our best to refocus. And I think the reason that we enjoy it so much is because it gives us that chance to live our life by our values and reconnect. And I think sometimes life takes over
与他们的家人和社区在一起，他们真的觉得这是一种特权，他们真的很享受并从中受益。是的，绝对是这样。我认为当你想到斋戒时，每个人都会想，哦，你很长一段时间不能吃喝，这是真的。我认为当我们想到斋月时，它不仅仅是斋戒。所以我想当我们处于斋月时，这是一个反思和重新与信仰建立联系的时间。我觉得那是一个我们消除干扰的时间。所以我们尽最大努力重新聚焦。我认为我们如此享受它的原因是因为它给了我们按照价值观生活并重新连接的机会。我认为有时生活会占据主导地位，
and sometimes we move away from our values. that having that time sometimes helps us to realize kind of why our values are important to us but then also being able to kind of um reconnect and thinking about reflection as well because I think it's a big period of time where we reflect on ourselves and where we want to be but also reflecting on those who are less fortunate to us and and helping those as well so kind of like um giving charity and things like that is something that's a big part of our religion to help other people lovely thank you so much and before we finish when we're working in services you know we have the right to um receive dignity respect and no hostility from people but when I've worked in services that hasn't always been the case and so it's just for us to to pay lip service to the fact that if you're not feeling like people are respecting you regardless of your culture regardless of your
有时我们会偏离我们的价值观。拥有那段时间有时会帮助我们意识到为什么我们的价值观对我们很重要，同时也能够重新连接，并思考反思，因为我认为这是一个很长的时间段，我们反思自己以及我们想去的地方，但也反思那些比我们不幸的人，并帮助他们。所以就像施舍之类的事情，是我们宗教中帮助他人的重要组成部分。太好了，非常感谢。在结束之前，当我们为服务机构工作时，你知道我们有权获得尊严、尊重，并且不受人们的敌意对待。但当我为服务机构工作时，情况并非总是如此。所以我们只是要口头上承认，如果你觉得人们没有尊重你，无论你的文化、背景如何，或者也许是因为你的文化和背景，你不需要容忍服务使用者提供的任何不合格的待遇。在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）内，对于接受这种行为有零容忍程序。因为文化和信仰而排斥和针对他人是刑事犯罪。我希望你没有遇到过这种情况。但我知道在现代英国，对于所有穆斯林来说，情况并非总是如此。是的，我认为当我反思我自己的经历时，我觉得有时确实如此。我认为有时很难识别，因为我觉得当我们思考多样性和包容性时，我觉得我们现在在心理学专业和英国更加多样化了。但我想当我们思考歧视之类的事情时，
background or perhaps in spite of your culture and background that you don't need to tolerate any kind of substandard treatment from service users. And certainly within the NHS, there's a zero tolerance process for accepting that. And that is a criminal offence to rule people out and single people out because of their culture and their faith. And I hope that's not cropped up for you. But I know that in modern modern Britain certainly that's not always the case for for all Muslims. Yeah I think when when I'm reflecting on my own experiences I feel like it has been the case sometimes and I think sometimes it's very hard to identify I think because I feel like when we're thinking about diversity and inclusion, I feel like we are now kind of more diverse in the psychology profession and within the UK. But I suppose when we're thinking about discrimination and things like that,
无论你的文化背景如何，或者即便因为你的文化背景，你都不需要容忍来自服务对象的任何形式的劣质对待。在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）内部，对于这种行为绝对是零容忍的。因为文化和信仰而排斥或针对他人是刑事犯罪。我希望你没有遇到过这种情况。但我知道，在现代英国，对于所有穆斯林来说，情况并非总是如此。是的，当回顾我自己的经历时，我觉得有时确实存在这种情况，而且我认为有时很难识别，因为我觉得当我们思考多元化和包容性时，我觉得我们现在在英国的心理学专业领域确实更加多元化了。但我想当我们思考歧视之类的问题时，
I feel like within the UK, it can be quite subtle. Microaggressions. Yeah, definitely. Yeah. And I think sometimes it's very hard to kind of pinpoint and address when they are microaggressions. But I feel like they can be just as harmful as things that are kind of more straightforward and obvious. But I think when when we are thinking about our differences in cultures, I do feel like when we're thinking about service users, it can sometimes really, really help when we're working with service users to
我觉得在英国，这可能相当微妙。微攻击。是的，绝对是。是的。而且我认为有时很难指出和解决微攻击。但我感觉它们可能和那些更直接、更明显的事情一样有害。但我认为当我们思考我们文化上的差异时，我确实觉得当我们思考服务使用者时，在与服务使用者合作时，这有时真的非常有帮助，
think about what what you know our social graces and and thinking about the services of social graces and thinking about kind of the impact of culture religion and and loads of different kind of um diversities um but i suppose when we're working with clients we can kind of come come across that where we do kind of experience those microaggressions and i think it's it's important to reflect on that and i think in my own experiences i've done my best as i can as a practitioner but then kind of reflecting back in supervision and thinking actually that's not something that i i should have to tolerate so so where do we go from from here and i think supervision is a great place i think to be able to to identify um how that affects us because i think sometimes within
思考我们的社交礼仪，思考服务的社交礼仪，思考文化、宗教和各种不同多样性的影响。但我想当我们与客户合作时，我们可能会遇到这种情况，即我们确实经历了那些微攻击。我认为反思这一点很重要。在我的个人经历中，我作为从业者尽了最大的努力，但在督导中回顾并思考，实际上那不是我应该容忍的事情。那么我们从这里去向何方？我认为督导是一个很好的地方，可以识别这如何影响我们，因为我认为有时在
sessions we can think about kind of the impact on the services but when you're kind of being on the receiving end of microaggressions and and potential discrimination that's going to affect affect you as a person and i think that's where we can kind of identify how things can change or how you can be supported with that um which I think is really important as well um but yeah sorry I've completely forgot what the original question was that's all right you did really well I was just trying to google the name um because when you mentioned social graces I was trying to remember his name but it's John Burnham and his work around social graces and if anyone knows John um I have invited him on the podcast and i haven't heard
会谈中，我们可以思考对服务的影响，但当你处于微攻击和潜在歧视的接收端时，那会影响你作为一个人的感受。我认为这就是我们可以识别事情如何改变，或者你如何得到支持的地方，我认为这也非常重要。但是的，抱歉，我完全忘记了最初的问题是什么。没关系，你做得很好。我只是在尝试谷歌那个名字，因为当你提到社交礼仪时，我试图记住他的名字，但那是John Burnham，以及他关于社交礼仪的工作。如果有人认识John，我已经邀请他参加播客，但我还没有收到回复，
back but i'd love to have him on the podcast so um i have had the fortune of being taught by him a couple of times and i'd love to have him on so if you are working in a service with john burnham give him a prod and invite him on the podcast and get him to get in contact with me alicia thank you so much for today it's been such um a richly enjoyable rewarding um podcast episode i've really really enjoyed it it's been lovely getting to know more about you um and your culture and your faith and your work as well um if i could give out deeply inside places you know I'd give you one um because I think you sound so ready for training you really sound very thoughtful and um competent and professional and you know I feel like our young people are in safe hands with you thank you for so much for having me I think I feel really special for being able to kind of come on and share my experiences
但我很想让他参加播客。所以我曾有幸被他教过几次，我很想让他参加。所以如果你和John Burnham在同一个服务机构工作，提醒他一下，邀请他参加播客，让他和我联系。Alicia，非常感谢你今天参加。这是一个非常令人愉快、有意义的播客剧集，我真的很喜欢。了解更多关于你、你的文化、你的信仰以及你的工作真是太好了。如果我可以发放临床心理学博士名额，我会给你一个，因为我觉得你听起来已经为培训做好了准备，你听起来非常深思熟虑、胜任且专业。而且我知道我们的年轻人交给你很安全。非常感谢你邀请我。我觉得能来分享我的经历感到非常特别。
um but yeah if you were giving out Declan uh places I'd I'd take one so yeah well wishing you all the best with the upcoming season you know I don't know if you've got your application in already or whether you're about to to to get that ticked off and sent off um you don't have to queue at the post office like I did now it's more of an electronic process um but yeah wishing you the best of luck with this and yeah um do stay in my world please stay interact with my stuff on LinkedIn because I always love our little chats so thank you so much for joining me and for being our first aspiring psychologist on the aspiring psychologist podcast which took me almost 10 months thank you so much it was a pleasure to be able to be on here. Thank you so
是的，如果你在发放DClinPsy名额，我会接受一个。祝你即将到来的申请季一切顺利，我不知道你是否已经提交了申请，或者你是否即将完成并发送。你不需要像我当年那样在邮局排队，现在更多是电子流程。但祝你在这方面好运。请留在我的世界里，请在LinkedIn上与我的内容互动，因为我总是喜欢我们的小聊天。非常感谢你加入我，并成为《有抱负的心理学家》播客的第一位有抱负的心理学家，这花了我将近10个月的时间。非常感谢，能来到这里是我的荣幸。非常感谢
much for listening. I hope you found that as, you know, invigorating and interesting and inspiring as I did. I feel excited for Alicia's future. If you have really liked the idea of aspiring psychologists being on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. And you think you've got an interesting story to tell and you'd like to talk to me about it and talk to our listeners about it. Then please do slip into my DMs on my socials. You can find me, Dr. Marianne Trent, most places. Please do come and connect. I do really enjoy helping you celebrate your wins. So please do connect with me and if you would
你的收听。我希望你觉得这和我一样令人振奋、有趣和鼓舞人心。我为Alicia的未来感到兴奋。如果你真的很喜欢有抱负的心理学家参加《有抱负的心理学家》播客的想法，并且你认为你有一个有趣的故事要讲，并且你想和我谈谈，并告诉我们的听众，那么请务必在我的社交媒体上私信我。你可以在大多数地方找到我，Dr. Marianne Trent。请务必来联系。我真的很喜欢帮助你庆祝你的胜利。所以请务必与我联系，如果你
welcome even more support and encouragement do think about coming along to the aspiring psychologist membership where you can join us for 30 pounds a month and we think about ways of advancing you professionally and personally we've got all sorts of good stuff in there including monthly cbt formulation and skills as well as other guest sessions from other specialist people each month too looking at research psychodynamic approaches systemic cat approaches and loads more as well as your weekly chance to catch up with me ask me any questions you like and of course our monthly group zooms as well with me so yeah there's absolutely loads going on it's a lovely place to be so do please give it some consideration if you think it might be a good fit for you for more information check out the show
欢迎更多的支持和鼓励，请考虑加入《有抱负的心理学家》会员，你可以每月支付30英镑加入我们。我们思考在专业和个人方面提升你的方法。我们在那里有各种各样的好东西，包括每月的CBT公式化和技能，以及每个月来自其他专业人士的其他嘉宾会议，研究心理动力学方法、系统式CAT方法等等。还有你每周与我交流的机会，问我任何你想问的问题，当然还有我们每月的Zoom小组会议。所以是的，绝对有很多事情在进行，这是一个可爱的地方。如果你认为它可能适合你，请考虑一下。欲了解更多信息，请查看节目
notes or you can check out any of the links in my bios on my socials in the meantime do come and join us in the aspiringpiring Psychologist Community free group on Facebook. And we can talk about this episode and how perhaps your intersectionality crops up for you in psychology. So yeah, thank you again for being part of my world. And yeah, I'll look forward to catching up with you in our next episode, which will be available from 6am on Monday. Take care of you. tips and lessons to learn from so many things that you can try the aspiring psychologist if you're looking to become a psychologist
说明，或者你可以查看我社交媒体简介中的任何链接。同时，请加入我们在Facebook上的《有抱负的心理学家》社区免费小组。我们可以谈谈这一集，以及你的交叉性在心理学中是如何体现的。所以是的，再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分。是的，我期待在下一集中与你见面，该集将于周一早上6点发布。照顾好自己。有许多技巧和课程可以学习，如果你想成为一名心理学家，有很多事情可以尝试。
Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become
那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，主持人是Dr. Marianne Trent。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为
a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有完美的成为临床心理学家的方法，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。